SHE'S GOTTA GO
AND DO HER OWN THING.
AND SHE DOESN'T KNOW
HOW TO TELL HIM.
SO SHE DECIDES...
- I GOTTA WRITE A SONG.
BECAUSE THAT'S HOW--
WHEN YOU'RE DOLLY PARTON,
THAT'S HOW YOU EXPRESS
YOURSELF.
- SHE SITS HIM DOWN,
AND SHE SINGS TO HIM.
- I WILL ALWAYS LOVE YOU...
I WILL ALWAYS LOVE YOU.
- FACT...
IT'S PROBABLY THE MOST
BEAUTIFUL SONG
THAT'S EVER BEEN WRITTEN.
AND IF YOU--
IF YOU LISTEN TO THAT SONG,
IN THE COURSE OF THAT SONG
SHE MAKES THIS PROMISE
TO PORTER WAGONER...
- I WILL ALWAYS LOVE YOU.
- AND HE SAYS...
- THAT IS THE MOST
BEAUTIFUL THING
I'VE EVER HEARD IN MY LIFE.
THAT'S THE BEST SONG
YOU'VE EVER WRITTEN.
OF COURSE YOU CAN GO.
- [laughs]
THIS IS SO FUN.
THIS IS THE MOST FUN
I'VE EVER HAD IN MY LIFE.
I'M GONNA LITERALLY INSTAGRAM
THIS [bleep] RIGHT NOW.
WHERE'S MY PHONE?
SHE GOES TO NEW YORK CITY,
AND SHE WALKED STRAIGHT INTO
THE "ARSEAY" OFFICES.
- YEAH, IT'S ME, DOLLY PARTON.
HERE'S WHAT'S ABOUT
TO HAPPEN.
I'M LEAVING
THE PORTER WAGONER SHOW.
I'M GETTING BRAND NEW
PRODUCERS,
I WILL BE BRIDGING
COUNTRY MUSIC AND POP.
I'M GONNA BE IN MOVIES.
ARE YOU IN, OR ARE YOU OUT?
BACK ME OR BACK THE [bleep] OFF.
- AND THEY'RE ALL, LIKE...
- COOL, WE'RE IN.
- YEAH. ABSOLUTELY, WE'RE IN.
- YEAH, YOU'RE--YEAH,
YOU'RE [bleep] DOLLY PARTON.
- YEAH, GREAT.
LET'S DO THIS [bleep].
- AND SHE DOES EXACTLY WHAT
SHE SAID SHE WOULD DO
TO THOSE "ARSEAY" EXECUTIVES.
SHE STARTS RECORDING
POP MUSIC.
AND PORTER WAGONER--
PORTER...WAGONER...
ONLY THOUGHT ABOUT HIMSELF.
PORTER WAGONER
SUES DOLLY PARTON.
HE BASICALLY SAYS...
- I WANT 15% OF WHAT YOU DID,
I WANT 15% OF WHAT
YOU'RE DOING,
AND I WANT 15%
OF WHAT YOU'RE GONNA DO.
- AND DOLLY PARTON IS LIKE...
- [bleep]!
PORTER WAGONER,
JUST CHILL.
CHILL OUT, MAN!
- SO SHE'S LIKE...
- LET'S SETTLE OUT OF COURT.
- AND WAGONER'S LIKE...
- COOL, I'LL TAKE $1 MILLION.
I'D LIKE $1 MILLION.
- WHAT DOES SHE DO NEXT?
UM, ONLY MAKES
HER FIRST MOVIE.
DOLLY PARTON IS MAKING 9 TO 5.
SHE'S MAKING BEST LITTLE
WHOREHOUSE IN TEXAS.
SHE'S CRUSHING IT.
PORTER WAGONER,
DURING THIS TIME,
HE'S OFF BLOWING MONEY.
HE'S GIVING JEWELRY OUT TO THE
WOMEN AND [bleep] LIKE CRAZY.
HE BUYS A [bleep] ORANGE GROVE!
HE OWES THE IRS $500,000.
BUT DOLLY PARTON MADE A PROMISE
TO PORTER WAGONER
THAT SHE WOULD ALWAYS
LOVE HIM.
AND SHE DID...